what's going on everybody welcome to
another python 3 basics video in this
video what we're going to be talking
about is list manipulation within python
so the last video we talked about tuples
versus lists and we said that lists are
mutable which means we can manipulate
them change them and all sorts of fun
stuff and there's a lot of built-in
things that we can do with lists so we
don't have to program our own ways
around it so with that let's go ahead
and get started first we're going to
need an example list so let's just make
an example list you do not have to copy
my exam exact uh list feel free to make
your own i'm just making numbers up
right now
there's my list uh so now the next thing
that we want to do is like let's say
you've got this list and you want to add
something to it you see we only have one
two three four twos we want one more two
so let's say we want to add another two
well that's going to be append right so
it's just like writing files right
append you're just adding something to
the end so we can do uh the following x
dot append
two and what this is going to do is it's
gonna modify this x variable okay so
it's just gonna automatically add this
so it's changing the variable of x so
uh now when we print x
we can run this and we see that we
started with seven two and now it's
seven two
two okay
so that's how we can add um
add information so a list can really
contain anything so i was going to say
add a number but actually you can add
numbers you can really add any any sort
of python data type you can boom sub it
in there so a python list doesn't have
to be just numbers or strings and so you
can do a lot of really fun stuff with
this especially
later on we'll talk about dictionaries
which you can do even more fun stuff
with but anyway more on that later
now what if
you want to insert a number or add a
number
and you don't want it to go to the end
while you use insert which is what i was
thinking and that's why i said it but
anyway you use insert so instead of
append to let's say we want to insert
two
and
what we can do the first uh
i might have these flips the first one
uh is where you want to insert it so the
element id that you want it where you
want to insert it and then the second
one is what is the value that you want
to insert so let's say we want to insert
into
index of 2 and we want to insert 99 so
we actually are positive that we we
inserted it correctly um so let's do
that so let's save and run that all
right so in the second
second index spot so again this is
zeroth first second uh we didn't enter a
99.
so that's how you can insert data
exactly where you want it so sometimes
append isn't exactly what you want
now uh what if you actually want to
remove data so we've talked about how we
add how do we get rid of data well uh
simple as remove
x dot remove and this is going to remove
the first example so here we have a lot
of twos let's say we want to get rid of
one of the twos um
we'll just do two we'll print x so this
this list will do five six one basically
because we removed the first
two from this list
simple enough
um the other thing that we could do is
you can remove say you wanted to remove
uh
you know the third element or or let's
let's get this two removed again but
let's say we want to remove it a little
differently so we can remove like this
we can say remove the x
uh two right so we can do something like
that
and we've still removed
that two so we're saying here we want to
remove the third element in the list but
the index value of two right so that is
the third element but anyway so that's
how you do that um so that's how you can
remove not only the specific number or
you can even reference the number that
you want to remove using the list that
you're trying to remove from
uh the next thing that we want to do is
we already know that we can reference
that with this so
again we showed it in the last video but
just in case you forgot you can
reference data so x
the
item in x the list of x right with an uh
index value of five so that should be
zero one two three four five that should
be a seven saving run that sure enough
it's a seven
that's how we can reference that data uh
another thing we do is what's called
slicing so we can get a slice of this
data so say we want to get
x from the you know element id of or
index of 5 to the index of 7 we can get
that slice so it prints seven two and it
stops goes from the first element right
and then it goes up to the ending
element so as you can see we didn't get
three we got two elements so it printed
the uh index of
five the end is of six and then it
stopped because it had reached seven so
again here we go there's a few more
elements for you so we'll close out of
this uh so that's how you can access a
slice also if you want to access you
know maybe let's say you want to access
the last element of the list you would
use negative one so that will give us a
two okay you can do the same thing you
could say negative two that will give us
a seven okay so that's how you can kind
of go to the end of a list as well
so
now one of the other things i want to do
is we can say
print let's say x say we want to print
um
say you want to know
what let's say you want to get rid of
the six oh let's say let's see if we
haven't okay one one is only occurs once
let's say you want to get rid of the
number one in this list but you don't
know it's a number one
or you want to know the element id of
number one let's just say for whatever
reason you want to know the or rather
the index value of the number one in
this list what you would do is at x dot
index
one so this is just going to tell us
what is the index value of one right now
this doesn't make sense but i'll show
you in a moment why this will be useful
uh to get the index value right now it
might not matter to you but when it what
happens is when you have two lists that
are in
relation to each other and you can get
the element or the index value of one
item in its list you can immediately
find the corresponding value in the
other list why you would do that over a
dictionary i'm not positive but you
might find yourself needing this so
anyway we'll show it anyways so print x
index 1 the index value of one is three
sure enough zero one two three we were
right yay
the other thing that we can do is say we
are curious uh how many of a certain
variable is in there certain
data is in there uh what we can do is x
dot count
um and we can do count and let's say we
want to know how many sixes there are so
print x dot count
uh and we have three
there is literally a dog under me
snoring i'm so sorry if you guys are
hearing that anyway i think i woke them
up
anyway uh so let's count we can count
how many uh values
of this are in there
the next thing that we can do with lists
is we can sort a list and generally a
list is actually very well python is
going to sort it intuitively so with
numbers it will sort it
you know numerically and if you have
text or string data in here it's going
to sort it alphabetically so let's just
show an example so print x dot sort
oops
actually what we want to do is this
sorry we don't want to print it
so we'll do x.sort and then we'll print
x
like that okay so
what i did there is you can't really
print x dot source sort is a function
that is being run
on x so when you do x dot sort again
lists are mutable so this is actually
changing the x uh list right now so
that's why i couldn't get away with
printing it but anyway so x sort then we
print x and we see that it was sorted
numerically for us nice the other thing
that we could do is let's say we have
another list y equals and we have some
names in here we have uh
janet
we've got
jessie i like those j's man we've got
kelly
we've got
alice we've got a joe
and we've got a bob
okay
we can do y.sort
print oops
print y
save and run that and we can see that
this was sorted alphabetically for us so
we don't actually have to say hey sort
this alphabetically or so sort this by
number it just kind of does it but if
you want to sort of list that's how you
can do it
and uh so this i think that'll be it at
least for list manipulation we'll be
covering some more uh in the next video
as far as like showing two different
lists
the next video i think we're going to
cover probably doing a csv file and then
and then i'll show you how you can um
why that find functionality was was
useful so anyways anybody has any
questions or comments i kind of ran
through a lot of the things that we can
do with lists hopefully i did a decent
job of just covering the tip of the
iceberg here when it comes to list
manipulation if you guys have any
questions or comments leave them below
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time